in this video we'll talk about an
important syndrome known as viscot
Aldritch syndrome this is a highly topic
for USMLE step one
Scott eldrich syndrome is a rare genetic
immunodeficiency that keeps a child's
immune system from functioning properly
or optimally
this is associated with the mutation in
WASP Gene
it is also makes it difficult for the
child to produce platelets so abnormally
small platelets are found in the child
with wasp syndrome
now it's mostly common in males when we
think about the genetics we've got
Aldrich syndrome shows x-linked
recessive pattern of inheritance
viscard Aldrich syndrome is
characterized by abnormal immune system
function which leads to actually
immunodeficiency
in blood the IGG and IGM levels are
pretty low whereas IGA and ige levels
are elevated
eczema or inflammatory skin rash is
pretty common in these children
then reduced ability to form blood clots
are pretty evident because the platelets
are very small compared to normal
patients
so there is a cool mnemonic to remember
all the symptoms it's known as water so
wna stands for viscot Aldrich t for
thrombocytopenia because the platelets
are abnormal e for eczema and R for
recurrent pyogenic infection obviously
if you don't have IGM and IGG there
would be recurrent infection with
bacteria right
now let us talk about the biology behind
the wash syndrome so the gene wasp
encode for a protein known as wasp and
this is a cytoskeletal regulator
it actually modulates actin branching it
interacts with another protein known as
arp23 which regulates branching of
actines
and this branching and cytoskeletal
rearrangement of acting is really
important for immune cell because they
need to move from one place to another
place and that's why their cytoskeletal
elements need to be dynamic they need to
squeeze through a narrow pore in the
blood vessel that is why cytoskeletal
rearrangement and the capability of this
is really important for the immune cells
especially the immune cell which is
affected is the T cell
so T-cell activation process is
abrogated in this particular symptom
also the interleukin-2 which is crucial
for tc950 cell proliferation that is
also reduced in this symptom
so when the T cells are non-optimal it
can be categorized as t or B cell
disorder
and when the T cell or the cell mediated
immunity is not proper then pyogenic
infections are pretty much recurrent
so in terms of diagnosis peripheral
blood smear can give us some idea about
the whiskat Ulrich syndrome because
there would be abnormally small
platelets shown here in this diagram
also immunological level of iggm and all
the other antibodies can be possibly
checked to understand whether there is
viscot Aldrich syndrome is not the
definitive diagnosis is genetic
sequencing but which is costly in nature
then let's talk about the treatment
option one of the treatment option is uh
hematopoietic chloride stem cell
transplant another option is intravenous
immunoglobulin injection on a weekly or
like a twice weekly basis
so there is no definitive treatment for
this disease but managing the symptom
would help the patient to thrive for
longer and improve the lifestyle but
with the Improvement of crispr cas9 and
other genome editing technology who
knows that was a mutation can be treated
and repaired
so that's for future but so far if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe follow us on Instagram and
Facebook the link is provided in the
description you can support us using
super tanks you can pay via Paypal UPI
or paytm see you in next video